[Music]
i think that for a lot of watchers of
action anime there's one thing that they
look forward to
fights we're talking battles high octane
action
and flashy cuts that showcase the
animators at their best the good news is
that there's no shortage of those in
anime anime is really one of the best
places to go if you like
battles whether they be the fantastic
ones with magic or testosterone-filled
slugfests
looking at the likes and view count on
the previous video it seems that you
guys
really like hand-to-hand combat in anime
so for this video we'll be going through
10 more of the best hand-to-hand fights
from anime in this video in particular
i've also gone through the effort of
adding some fights from some of the less
popular anime out there
i hope that by the end of this video i
would have introduced you to one or two
titles that you may not have heard of
before so without further ado
let's get started
before most of the shows that put them
on the map came into existence
production ig had a hand in producing
one of the sci-fi shows that fell
under the radar in the late 2000s i'm
talking about
real drive as early as its fifth episode
real drive already treated its audience
with a pretty good fight with some great
hand-to-hand action
in this episode we have sort of taking
on the fearsome iron schwartz
to put it bluntly sorta at this point
has been a flunk
we see glimpses of his defeat at the
hands of holland haunting him
and thinking about that isn't exactly a
winning recipe for any fighter
nonetheless assorted gets to show off
some moves here and there
and with some intervention manages to
win the battle against iron
overall i think that real drive is a
nice show with some cool fights and
visuals i probably wouldn't call it too
underrated but i think it's a decent
series that could use some more
popularity then again with so many good
anime coming out this past decade i
wouldn't be surprised if people don't
even remember real drive
guintama's 141st episode gave us this
one highlight of a fight featuring
kagura's elder brother
finding himself in battle against the
humongous hosen
he gives us a great showcase of his
close quarter combat ability
the action is fast and furious with the
two going at it in a battle that pits
strength against speed the action itself
was quite tough given how fast
everything moves and the hotly contested
battle
between two strong fighters ended in a
draw i don't know about you but to me it
seemed that hosum was a lot stronger
than his opponent in this fight this
fight still starts discussions every now
and then when it comes to gintama
fanbase i mean realistically kamui could
have been screwing around
given his personality that is a
possibility i wonder what could have
happened if both people went
all out in a fight to the death
i think that birdie the mighty as a
series is quite underrated
it's fun it has a lot of great action
scenes and while the art might seem
dated by modern standards
it doesn't distract from the awesomeness
of scenes such as this fight in
particular now this fight stood out for
me for some reason such as the high
octane action and just how dynamic it
looks
you have two combatants engaging in
hand-to-hand combat that spills all over
the place
with the ruined city backdrop adding a
nice touch now that i think about it
doesn't it remind you of a superhero
fight somewhere
the whole sequence wouldn't look out of
place in one of them i wouldn't blame
you if that's what you think actually
this is the fight that inspired the last
fight in man of steel if i'm not
mistaken i'd say that snyder picked one
amazing fight for his inspiration this
show deserves to be far more popular if
you ask me
now i'm positive that a lot of hajime no
hippo fans would agree with me
when i say that kimura had one of the
great character arcs
and everything culminated in his
championship fight in the ova i feel
like this is one of the more underrated
fights in the series
and kimura's determination and drive
earned him more than a fair share of
fans
it's a given that hajime no ipo has a
lot of great hand-to-hand fights but
this takes the cake for featuring one
character that still needs some love
kimura's
fight against mashiba is bar none the
highlight of the execution arc and it
showcases the best techniques that the
two combatants use to fight each other
the tense fight includes a final
exchange where both fighters hit each
other
and mashiba wins just by the skin of his
teeth even if he didn't win the match
kimura got himself a lot more fans for
his
excellent showing that can be seen in
hajime no ippo's ova
[Music]
coming in the sixth spot we have a fight
from the newest rising star in the world
of martial arts series
kengan ashura i think that those who've
watched ken gunn ashura would have at
least one fight to remember over the
course of the series for me it's the one
that pit
omar and ryan against each other the two
come face to face in the second round of
the kangaroo annihilation tournament the
battle between the two turned out
somewhat like you'd expect
early on ryan finds himself on the ropes
pressured by the flurry of attacks by
the upstart omar
however it doesn't take long before the
one called the devil turns the tables
delivering one hell of a beatdown in
return a back and forth exchange with
the combatants releasing power after
power ends with omar clutching a victory
with his nico style
this is just one of those back and forth
fights that make martial arts anime so
fun to watch
if i was recommending a fight to someone
in order to get them to watch kangan
ashura
this one would be one of the top
contenders seriously if you haven't
watched this series and are craving for
some manly fighting anime
then this is a good choice to consider
it's either this or the very next series
up on the list
bucky 2018 prides itself on some of the
most outrageous fight sequences
and this fight is a showcase of what the
series brings to the table
it's simply insane just take a look at
it i don't know how else to describe
this fight between speck and hanayama
the two trade blows
but it really felt more like a clash
between two giants
two indomitable titans the two chunks of
muscle take each other to the limit
showing off some techniques that are
just as absurd as they are good
this goes on for quite a while before
hanayama finishes the fight by simply
brutalizing spec to the point of
surrender the cool thing with barky
though is despite the spectacle you see
in fights like this
there are still some real techniques
being shown baki 2018 might be edging
towards jojo territory in its fights and
character designs
but at its core it's still a good old
martial arts series
a key episode in season two of attack on
titan is the one where aaron and reina
duke it out in their titan forms
emotions are already running high thanks
to the revelation of the identities of
the colossal and armored titans
this battle pushed those emotions over
the edge as the titans clash in the
highlight of this episode we're used to
seeing aaron bludgeoning his opponents
as a titan
but such a tactic might not stick with
reiner this time around
they don't call him the armored titan
for nothing you know and in a direct
confrontation
aaron has all the disadvantage in the
world except he doesn't
thanks his experiences as a human
ultimately it's the training with annie
from way back that allowed aaron to get
the advantage and come out on top in
this battle
fighting smart for once eren shows
tremendous signs of growth
however victory is short-lived as the
colossal titan
or what remains of it crashes the party
and joins the battle
capping off an excellent first season of
one punch man is this fight between
saitama
and boros the leader of the invasion
forces no slouch
being responsible for the destruction of
a city through the dark matter thieves
boros has even grown tired of
competition having grown so strong the
enemies already bore him reminds you of
someone among the good guys does that
hey having saitama and boros face off in
the climax of one punch man's first
season
seems to be a match made in heaven in
terms of the actual fight
i think that it delivered giving us some
of the most amazing scenes and sequences
in modern anime history
you can really feel the destructive
power of the attacks and how hard
each attack hits through the effects i
put this fight as third on the list
because despite the raw
hype generated from the fight itself and
the way the whole thing is presented
it's not exactly a fight
come on it's saitama and we all know
saitama battles can't really be called
fights can they
especially given his moniker
it's been a long time coming but we
finally see naruto and sasuke in action
again
in boruto this time instead of them
fighting each other like we've become
accustomed to
it's surely a breath of fresh air to see
them work together
in order to take down a new threat
nostalgia goggles aside i really think
that this is one of the better fights in
the series
watching this battle you can't help but
feel the intensity of it all the
soundtrack certainly helps matters
and you can see the teamwork and
chemistry that the duo always had in
action the animation for this fight is
simply
amazing and that's something that few
can replicate in my opinion this is
easily one of the most ambitious
projects in terms of animation
and kudos to the team for living up to
the hype i know how people feel about
boruto as a sequel but i really think it
has some really well animated fights and
this fight featuring the old characters
showing that they still have it is just
one of the many great action sequences
and emotional fights
that boruto has to offer
when it comes to fights we've gotten so
used to seeing made-up techniques or
otherwise mundane attacks being given
the upgrade and becoming grand
spectacles
but not here in this fight from hitori
noshita we see some of the smoothest
fighting animation from anime that have
come out in recent years
rarely do we see something like tai chi
being represented in anime combat but
the team did an epic job in showcasing
how cool the martial art is or while
making it look slick and awesome as hell
kudos to the team for featuring one of
the less popular and more graceful
fighting stars in the world
are making it accurate and at the same
time very cool it's also the return
of boruto's episode 65 team and we all
know how great that momoshiki fight was
real martial arts enthusiasts would
surely appreciate how this episode
delivered in accuracy
and choreography
[Music]
well that's going to do it for this list
hopefully you guys found a new show to
watch thanks to this video if you're up
for more content like this then don't
hesitate to like
subscribe and hit that sweet bell button
so you can be the first in line when it
comes to new uploads
as always stay tuned for more content
like this i hope you enjoyed this list
stay safe and stay strong and i'll see
you next time
on vini tube
[Music]
you